john ashraf is the ceo of neurogym and
one of the
leading mindset and behavior experts in
the world he went from being a teen who
was often getting in trouble with the
law
to writing two best-selling books being
featured in eight movies including the
blockbuster hit the secret and building
five
multi-million dollar companies
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
top
nation
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best john aseroff and my take on his top
10 rules to success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one make
a change in many cases with adults we
have to unlearn
what we learned in the past what we
learned in the past and
one of my friends wrote a really good
book it says what got you here
won't get you there so
if yeah if you want to
achieve another result that you've never
achieved before
who is he um marshall goldsmith
okay yeah and um wonderful wonderful man
and so if we want to achieve another
result that we've never achieved before
then we have to become somebody
different
we have to upgrade our skills we have to
upgrade our behaviors we have to
master our emotions better because we're
going to meet resistance
yes and we don't like change the human
brain and body doesn't like change i've
said for
30 years now the only human being that
likes change
is a baby with a wet diaper
yeah as the only human being that likes
change everybody else likes
i like everything just the way it is
yeah and so
and as we get older it becomes harder
and harder to change because the
patterns in the brain are so strong
if you think about an oak tree yes and
if you looked underneath
the ground to the root system it's
connected to
all the other oak trees maybe for miles
around
all interconnected it's hard to change
it's hard to change it because you can
pull the oak tree but you still have all
the roots that are connected
and if you had a little baby tree that's
maybe been there for one year
it's much easier to go in and pull the
tree out
and take the root system out and so as
we get older
we become more and more conditioned to
be
more and more the same
so it's not that change isn't possible
it's most people aren't willing to
commit
to switching from what's comfortable
to what's not long enough for the
new to be comfortable rule number two
have
awareness while you're in the you know
in the
uh what am i thinking feeling it's a
chance to be aware and
the biggest gift we have as human beings
is
our awareness because awareness is what
gives you choice
and choice is what gives you freedom
most people are living their lives in a
reactive state
automatic reactive state because of
these set points that we talked started
talking about so we're in this
repetitive cycle over and over and over
and over we react to the same things we
behave the same way we eat the same
foods we dress the same way
just to maintain that homeostasis and
comfort zones and we've never been
taught like
when were we taught as kids like here
are your six core emotions
here's the way you deactivate you know
your stress center or fear so here's how
you activate your imagination center
here's how you have more focus here's
how you develop a new belief here's how
you develop a new habit here's how you
release one
we haven't been taught that we've been
told they're important things
but we haven't been given the tools and
then we haven't practiced the tools
enough to be able to make them part of
our
unconscious competence brain rule number
three work
on your brain we started to retrain our
agents brains after we did a
we did a uh an event 75 agents paid i
think it was
two or three thousand dollars to go
through a six month brain retraining
program
those 75 agents increased our sales by a
hundred million dollars
wow and we said okay we're gonna teach
this to the entire company
yeah so we went from a billion two to
four point five billion in sales a year
in three years by working on this versus
what they needed to do
rule number four override the wrong
patterns
what you'll see is just patterns
patterns and more patterns the entire
universe
is made up of patterns that could be
explained
mathematically for the most part but we
can also just see
behaviors and so there it's not
it's not difficult
but it's it's it's it takes effort
to be able to override some of the
natural
you know brains propensity the brain's
desire to keep us away from hurting
ourselves to re-educate our brain
yeah and if you think about you know
when we have when we
when we're young what do our parents do
well be careful oh don't fall down
or watch out how you ride the bicycle
you know and if you fall down well
my kids when you know when they were
young i let them fall and i let him do
things
so that they would get accustomed get up
i wouldn't go and and and you know um
baby them they'd fall down i was like
great you fell down get back up
because they learned that it's okay yeah
most kids when they fall down they'll
look at an adult to see well
is it okay or not it's okay or not and
usually the adults are either gonna baby
them
and and over compensate or they're gonna
look at them just come on get up and
and and you know do what you need to do
hey this john asref and do you love good
books
i love to read because there's so much
wisdom in books
you get to take somebody else's
knowledge skills research
pay 15 20 bucks and you learn so much
now i'm reading this awesome book called
built to serve
find your purpose and become the leader
you were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and um i'm going to read a
little bit from
chapter number one and um
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent at something
everybody has a michael jordan talent at
something you just haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you were
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so lots of pearls and gems and
motivational pieces
pick pickup built to serve evan
carmichael
rising star rule number five develop
new beliefs think about what is a belief
and let's go to again i like just like
to go to the neuroscience fields because
just
my passion now is a belief is nothing
more than
a group of cells that have been
connected
and then reinforced and we have two
types of beliefs
we have beliefs that are really fast i'm
going to stop you there because that's
so
important yeah and so different than i
would have expected i think
when people hear belief it is believing
something that is true
which did not enter into your definition
no
we believe whatever we believe is
truth for us but it's not the truth
that's really interesting right but we
have been conditioned
if we go back a little bit to um what we
talked about earlier about
you know when you were a baby when you
were born what belief did you have
zero goose egg zero not one
and so you learned what to believe and
how to even
formulate your beliefs chances are from
parents
teachers brothers sisters television
maybe when you read some books right and
we behave based on what we believe
so we might be behaving our lives away
based on
false or inaccurate or disempowering
beliefs
so if a belief is a neural pattern in
the brain
then we probably have some good ones
empowering ones
useful ones and chances are we have some
that are not
useful not empowering and not worthy of
the geniuses that we all are so the
question is
is it possible for me to develop
new beliefs that i don't believe right
now the answer is yeah
rule number six hang out with successful
people
the key factors to becoming a loser
let's imagine that
together we build the training to help
people become a loser yeah
repeatedly thinking feeling and doing
the wrong things every day
okay great things okay do you have
another one
hanging around with the wrong people
your environment is it working your
environment
shapes who you are okay very very much
when i was getting into trouble
as a young man the people that i was
hanging around with
we're also getting into trouble when i
was a little boy i remember
my father he used to tell me he says
show me who your friends are
and i'll tell you who you are yeah and
so
you're gonna be the sum
of the people that you invest the most
amount of time with
whether it's at home your friends your
family or your business
people so if you tend to be around
winners
you'll start to by by sheer
environmental factors listen and learn
how they think you'll be able to observe
what they do
you'll learn the skills that they've
acquired
and if you hang around with losers
you'll see
patterns everything in life is about a
pattern
and so people who are unsuccessful and
losers
which i don't even like to use the the
term
loser although there are some not a lot
um they have got habitual patterns of
destruction
self-sabotaging thoughts and
self-sabotaging behaviors
and people who are successful i don't
mean just
financially people who are successful in
their health their relationships
charitable contributions they have
consistent
successful patterns that are
constructive
towards being successful rule number
seven set
high goals after i you know gone to real
estate and i traveled the world
i um i ended up buying the franchising
rights for re max for the state of
indiana
and i was 26 years old and i bought the
franchising rights for india and i moved
to indiana
and um i remember being interviewed for
the indianapolis business journal and
the guy said what are your goals here in
indiana
26 years old i was wearing you know i
remember a
brown pinstripe suit uh i had glasses on
even though i didn't need glass i just
want to look older
and i said we'll do a billion dollars in
sales in indiana
and the gentleman said to me says are
you certain of that i said well that's
my goal
he says well their two largest companies
have been here for a hundred years
don't do a hundred million dollars a
hundred
or a billion dollars combined and my
cocky
young self i said will be first yeah
three weeks later in the in-app's
business journal and i have it at home
it says
sets one billion dollar goal wow um
may 1992 we hit a billion dollars in
sales five years later
rule number eight use repetition one of
the things that i was taught
playing sports was repetition
is the mother of skill repetition is the
mother of skill
which is another lesson that i learned
at a very young age
why does any piano coach
guitar coach
coach for sports have their students
repeat drills over and over and over and
over again whether it's layups
or free throws or playing you know
certain
chords on the guitar or on the piano why
is repetition so important
the answer is because when you
repeat a pattern over and over and over
again whether it's
a language pattern an emotional pattern
or a behavioral pattern
when you repeat it over and over and
over and over again
20 times 50 times 100 times 200 times
500 times a thousand times
you actually are creating patterns in
the brain
that initially go from being conscious
patterns patterns that require
effort and intention and attention your
conscious mind
to patterns that become non-conscious
that require
less energy and less attention because
it's been repeated so many times it
becomes second
nature rule number nine start with why
you have to use intrinsic and extrinsic
motivation so you have to
start everybody off well why is it
important for you to be able to develop
these new beliefs
like what would your life be like if you
had them right now
what would your family life be like you
have to give them
a benefit that's greater than the switch
cost
that's interesting right so the switch
cost
is something that our brain resists the
only human that likes change is a wet
baby
every other human being is resistant to
it because
safety first and homeostasis and energy
conservation
so we are biologically wired not to want
to change
so we have to deliberately coax the
brain
into motivational reasons emotional
reasons
you have to have intrinsic reason why
must you do this and so you can use
pain as a frame as well so if you don't
then
are you okay with your life being like
this at this age in five years and 10
years and 20 years
and if you're okay with that then you're
not a candidate for change
but if you're committed to letting go of
the old so you can create the new
and you create motivations every day
that's where the power is remember
earlier progress not perfection
so anybody can do one minute or
or 10 seconds so if you can start to
formulate a habit a daily habit a weekly
habit
it doesn't matter how long it is if you
can
create that space in your brain that on
this day
at this time this is what i do and you
do that repeatedly
that becomes a habit and it takes those
66 days or so for a simple habit that
you have to consciously
do to then the habit doing you and rule
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is find mentors for the last
you know 35 years you know what i've
been doing
is i've had coaches for
skill training i've had coaches and
mentors
for mindset training i've had coaches
on brain training i've had coaches for
business skills and training
i've had coaches and mentors and experts
for every different area of my life
whether it's health
nutrition business money investing
getting out of debt making more money
protecting your assets
there are experts for every single area
of our lives
that already know what you need to do
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
a lot of people are stressed right now
why text
phone mobile radio tv facebook uh
twitter
all this it's just non-stop stress in
the brain
and when the brain feels stressed then
obviously cortisone
cortisone cortisol epinephrine
norepinephrine kick in and that's a
stress hormone
well it's like having you know your
finger on the electricity button all day
long and just not not stopping so you
start to burn
the fibers um your nerves
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there